[? ALICIA: ?] Hi.
I'm [? Alicia, ?]
and today I'm super
excited to talk
about Apigee X, which
is the latest release of Google
Cloud's Apigee API Management
Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Businesses have been executing
on digital transformation
strategies for many years.
However, the COVID-19
outbreak drastically
changed consumer behavior
and work environments,
forcing businesses to
quickly adapt and accelerate
their efforts to meet
new digital demands,
such as delivering a connected,
seamless digital experience,
automating as many manual
processes as possible,
operating anywhere with
distributed remote workforce,
and unlocking new
revenue streams.
In order to meet
these new demands,
organizations
should really think
beyond digital
transformation and strive
to achieve digital excellence.
APIs are key to driving
digital excellence.
They enable companies to
deliver seamless experiences,
modernize applications, abstract
the complexity of legacy
systems, and unlock
new revenue streams.
As enterprises rapidly
scale and globalize
their digital
transformation programs,
their underlying API programs
follow correspondingly.
Therefore, businesses need a
very comprehensive and powerful
API management platform to
support the new digital needs.
Apigee X helps businesses
accelerate and globalize
their API programs to
achieve digital excellence.
It allows them to deliver
secure, high-performing,
reliable APIs across the globe
with an integrated approach
to artificial intelligence, web
application firewall, identity
management, content
delivery network,
and other advanced
Cloud capabilities.
Let's take a closer look.
Apigee X comes with out
of the box integration
with Cloud CDN, which leverages
the same network that Google
uses to host its apps
used by billions of users.
This allows you to deploy it
and deliver high-performing APIs
across 24 regions and
73 zones with caching
across 93 points of presence.
It provides multiple layers
of security for your APIs,
eliminating the
need to integrate
with third-party solutions
for web application firewall
and identity management needs.
Apigee X is powered by Google
Cloud's industry-leading AI.
You can now apply
machine intelligence
to automate trivial tasks
related to API operations
and API security so that you
can really focus on business
critical activities.
Last but not least, it
provides the flexibility
to store data in the
region of your choice,
gives you more control
on encrypted data,
and ensures that
your business adheres
to all regulatory and
compliance requirements.
Let's see a quick demo
of how this works.
Apigee X provides
self-service capabilities
to create your own
orgs and environments.
To create an org,
simply click Edit,
select the Analytics
Hosting Region,
and enter the encryption key.
After configuring the network
and runtime parameters,
you can now create
an environment
by providing the
required details.
For the purpose of this demo,
I created a Hello World proxy,
added a few developers, and
registered a front-end app.
If I try to access the proxy
without a key, it fails.
To further protect this
proxy with Cloud Armor,
you can create a new rule
or apply an existing rule
to the API proxy.
When I try to access the same
proxy again without a key,
you'll see a change in the
error message generated
by Cloud Armor.
Now let's see how to apply Cloud
CDN capabilities to your APIs
for enhanced caching
and performance.
I created a very
simple CDN policy
and applied it to
the load balancer.
In addition, I
added cache control
so that Cloud CDN knows
to cache the responses.
When I access the
proxy from US West,
the call is executed in
about 10 milliseconds.
If I take the same
call and execute it
from a VM located
in Europe West,
the response time
for the first attempt
is about 215 milliseconds.
However, because of
the enhanced caching,
the response time for
the second attempt
goes down to 16 milliseconds.
This was just a quick
preview of Apigee X.
In summary, Apigee X
allows you to deliver
secure, high-performing,
reliable APIs
across the globe with
an integrated approach
to artificial intelligence, web
application firewall, identity
management, content
delivery network,
and other advanced
Cloud capabilities.
Now, it's your turn
to try it out and get
started by following the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]